>>Google Rep: San Francisco near base design
branding firm that he established in 1999.
He has also the chief creative officer at
Jawbone, you can see the jawbone up on his
wrist.
He has collaborated with renowned partners
such as Herman Miller, we are sitting in his
sail chairs.
[Laughter]
This isn't a product placement advertising
forum, but we try to celebrate who we bring
in.
Jawbone, GE, Puma, Prada and many others.
Yves Bahar believes that design should be
a force for positive social and environmental
change.
He is well known for his humanitarian work
on projects such as "One Laptop Per Child",
and "See Better To Learn Better."
For each of these he was honored with the
INDEX award, making him the only designer
to have received the award twice.
Bahar's works are included in the permanent
collections of museums worldwide including
the MoMA, the SFMoMA here in SF, the Centre
Pompidou and the Art Institute of Chicago.
Bahar's a frequent speaker on design, sustainability
and business topics.
He has given talks at TED, The World Economic
Forum in Davos, the Clinton Global Initiative
and now the Googleplex.
Please welcome Yves to the Googleplex.
[Applause]
>>Yves: thank you for the nice welcome.
>>Google Rep: I try to keep it a little bit
short.
So let's kick this off.
How and why did you become a designer?
>>Yves: Yeah, let's start with easy question.
[Laughter]
So I first became a designer because I wanted
to be a writer, I wanted to write stories.
I was a teenager, I was 12 or 13 years old
and in Switzerland there wasn't really a school
for design.
You know my parents weren't in design either.
So I wanted to be a writer, I wanted to tell
stories.
And my high-school teacher kind of discouraged
me from that which kind of, I slowly became
aware that it was possible to tell stories
through the mind.
And so it became my new passion and the thing
I dedicated myself to probably from the age
of 15 or so.
And slowly got my 10,000 hours by the time
I was 20.
>> Google Rep: Yeah Malcolm Gladwell's 10,000
hours.
>>Yves: Yep, and you know it's been all I
do and what I do since then.
So when it comes to telling stories, I brought
you a few slides cause you gave me a nice
list of questions which I think a lot of you
participated in coming up with.
But you know like when you get to work on
the type of project we work on, telling stories
and perpetuating stories has become what I
feel.
Not just, I can do it, but a lot of designers
can do.
And this is probably one of the nicest stories
and one of the nicest things that ever happened
in my career.
Which is Uruguay, having a stamp to support
and to speak of the $100 laptop.
>>Google Rep: Totally
>>Yves: Which every single child in Uruguay
between the age of 6 and 18 years old actually
has one.
Every child in public school has one of the
laptops.
I have a whole sheet of these stamps.
>>Google Rep: Yeah, the presentation isn't
just stamps though.
>>Yves: Plus my father.
So when I said my parents are not in design,
and my father was essentially, he's a philatelist.
And that was his sort of childhood passion,
so stamp collecting and being an expert at
stamps was his thing.
So after 25 years of practice and design,
I kind of got around to having a stamp.
>>Google Rep: Perfect.
So who's influenced you?
I mean you know if we think about some of
the, there was a recent exhibit of Dieter
Rams at SF MOMA (Museum of Modern Art).
And I went there and I was like wow Johnny
I've obviously receive such inspiration from
this.
You know is there an equally profound influence
on Yves Bahar?
>>Yves: You know, in many ways I feel, and
this is where I have another little visual.
Unfortunately they all look a little wider,
like they gained a little weight over lunch.
[Laughter]
There's a distortion on the screen.
So of course there's designers, 20th century
designers that have had a big influence on
me.
Whether it's Shoal Bass or Charles Eames or
George Nelson.
And I'm also a big admirer of people who have
built companies who have built businesses
out of processes that they've discovered and
that they've kind of owned through design.
You know somebody like Issey Miyake for example
which I was very lucky to do a couple of projects
with.
But it's less of a stylistic influence on
my part.
You know I'm not really style driven.
To me design, architecture or graphic design
isn't about just imprinting sort of style
and repeating it over time, it's really about
finding the context in which a design is gonna
be, and doing something unique or magical
or important in this particular area.
But I'm generally influenced by makers.
I would say people who make things whether
they're designers or entrepreneurs is kind
of what gets me out of bed in the morning.
And these guys were incredible makers of their
times.
Whether it was again graphics or furniture.
And in many ways have influenced not just
American design, but the whole world of design
sense.
And I think in many ways they were also the
best thinkers of their time.
You know, Charles Eames didn't really follow
a style.
You know for a few years, initially he really
created with the LC2 chairs, you know this
amazing way to bend plywood and then to kind
of have a similar style an plexiglass, or
fiberglass sorry.
But then he also went to aluminum with the
aluminum group chairs right.
And so you can't really speak of repetitive
style or signature across his work, but you
can speak of somebody fascinating, fascinated
by making, innovating and creating something
appropriate both from a socioeconomic set
point at its times.
But also sort of on the cusp of material and
technology innovations.
So those are, those are strong influences
in general in my career.
You know I'm a big fan of Dieter Rams as well.
But it's less because of his style and more
because of the way he was able to deeply influence
Brown, you know the company.
You know from a design point of view and help
the company build itself through design and
through brand.
>>Google Rep: So in 1999 you started Fuseproject.
Kind of what was your vision in starting Fuseproject
and is it still true today, kind of what you
hoped or seen it wanted to be when you start
a Fuseproject?
>>Yves: Yeah in 99 I started Fuseproject.
It was the high before the bubble burst, the
.com bubble.
I started it because I felt like a lot of
people were speaking about integration, how
different design fields were gonna come together.
How interaction design, user interface, industrial
design, packaging brand were gonna merge or
should merge.
But nobody in my opinion back then was practicing
it.
And so I became kind of obsessed almost about
practicing a form of design which actually
I had seen practiced in Eames office, I mean
not personally seen but I had spoken, my first
job was one with a person who had worked in
the Eames office.
And so I was fascinated with this notion of
a multidisciplinary place where we would literally
fuse all these different types of design disciplines
on our projects.
Of course when I started it was just me and
a computer so I the multidisciplinary designer,
but we built the team now to 250 really diverse
group.
And the name Fuseproject comes out of this
idea
>>Google Rep: Of fusing together things.
.>>Yves: Exactly.
>>Google Rep: Yeah.
So you mentioned Charles Eames, they had a
very unique shop down in LA.
Kind of how he described Fuseproject as a
culture or as a company?
>>Yves: so what I believe in is you know for
a while design got broken down into these
tiny little specialties.
Design got in a way almost obfuscated and
became very much relegated in the sort of
corporate food chain to providing a service.
A graphic design service.
You know brand or an app software or advertising
or strategy.
These became you know broken down.
And what was the most important factor in
the 80s and 90s was really marketing or advertising
in the way that you build the ethos or that
you build the way a company is known in the
world.
And then you build a brand.
And so what we believe is more of a 360°
process where everything influences the other
elements.
Always from a design point of view, but if
you're building a user experience, or the
name of a company or the way it's going to
present itself visually or a product.
We do all these things at the same time, sort
of in parallel rather than sequentially at
what was traditionally done in the 80s and
90s.
Which means that the team, the way the team
works and the culture is very much about that
as well.
So we all share desks, there is no divisions,
there's no departments in a sense.
There are practices, you know people come
from certain practice and they are good at
something but everybody has a voice in how
we build businesses and how we help companies
sort of build themselves by design.
And the same goes for seniority, there isn't
really a hierarchy of practices or a hierarchy
of seniority in the team.
So we tend to work around very collaboratively
around big tables.
We'll set up labs, as many labs as we can
that essentially study, research and develop
solutions to a certain problem.
And what you'll see is tons of materials,
you know sketches, drawings, diagrams, thoughts
being uploaded on walls and constantly sort
of picking up and put back up, taken down
and put back up.
So is not an ivory tower type of process at
all.
>>Google Rep: It's very hands-on.
>>Yves: It's very hands-on, very much about
making, very much about stress testing ideas
with design and building that as a multidisciplinary
team.
>>Google Rep: So it's interesting right, at
Google, if you look at a project we have a
PM, we have engineers, designers, they're
all distinct roles.
It sounds like it's in stark contrast to a
project, a Fuseproject where things are much
more organic and probably less controlled
or less structured.
>>Yves: Yeah, I don't know how structured
things are here.
Maybe we should ask the audience how they
feel.
>>Google Rep: Yeah maybe we can bring this
up later on.
>>Yves: But yeah, I would say that the idea
is to get sort of maximum amount of participation.
That said, our teams probably don't look that
different from yours.
I mean we have outside engineering firms,
outside developers, outside specialties that
come in and complement whatever we're doing
at the moment.
And people do come from a place of knowledge
and specialty maybe initially.
But they very quickly become sort of T-shaped
people you know in the sense that they have
deep knowledge of a certain area but they
become really, really good at understanding
the whole process and being able to participate,
plug-in in the whole process.
And because we're addressing, we're constantly
addressing new problems were not really working
on old problems.
We're really always addressing new challenges
or new types of companies or new types of
opportunities.
Those skills are fundamental for that.
>>Google Rep: So the approach they used on
the last project isn't necessarily immediately
applicable in your current project.
>>Yves: No.
I mean there's certainly an approach, but
the resolution is gonna be different.
There's certainly a way that we do things
you know, I'm not sure if that's covered in
other questions, but we start with ideas.
And then we build the products, companies,
expressions around those ideas.
>>Google Rep: Well it's probably a perfect
segue because one of the questions that definitely
came up when we kind of opened this up to
the community was kind of what are Yves Bahar's
10 principles right?
You know Dieter Rams has 10 principles that
have become very widespread if you're into
design.
So what would be the Yves Bahar equivalent
right that kind of guide?
Sorry.
>>Yves: I realize, I was like, I printed,
because I couldn't remember my own 10 principles.
And besides I don't really have them.
>>Google Rep: If you want to cheat, I actually
have them printed out.
>>Yves: Oh, okay.
[Laughter]
>>Google Rep: This wasn't scripted at all.
[Laughter[
>>Yves: I was looking, I left my own little
sheet with your questions and just a couple
ideas I wanted to touch upon in the car.
And I got here and I was all macho thinking
ah that's fine I'll figure it out.
But those, so a while back, this is something
I said about three or four years ago so it
may have evolved quite a bit.
But first of all my number one principle is,
design is how you treat your customer.
The best definition I can think of for design,
and people always ask me, "So what is good
design?"
And most people when they ask you this question,
they always think about you know what kind
of style or what should something look like
or feel like to be considered good design,
to enter a museum or to win a competition
or to win many, many customers.
And my answer here is not aesthetic, it's
really about how businesses practice what
they do, what they sell or the services they
offer should be about how they treat their
customers.
And design can significantly enhance that.
So if you treat your customer well from an
emotional standpoint, from an environmental
standpoint, from an ergonomic standpoint,
from a health standpoint, you probably are
doing good design.
The second one is for me design must be integrated
throughout the organization.
It isn't a sort of nice add-on at the end
of the process.
It isn't something that, it isn't a surface
layer, it isn't veneer.
Good design needs to live throughout the entire
organization to have an influence in the beginning
and to have an influence at the end.
And everywhere in between.
So the third one relates to that, design is
not a short-term fix, it's a long-term engagement.
That's the way we work.
There's lots of people who will call you up
and say, "Look we just need a logo", or "We
just need a website", and "You'll be done
in three months."
And that's not the way good design is done.
>>Google Rep: That's not a client you want?
>>Yves: It's not the kind of client we want,
but it's you know the clients I want depend
on mostly depend on what kind of quality I'm
gonna be able to create with them.
And so it's not about short-term fixes, it's
really about thinking long-term you know how
a company wants to build itself by design.
The fourth one is design must be driven from
the top.
This is a part of the discussion we had at
lunch, how you get people to stick to the
initial intent of design.
How do you get sort of the initial vision
to be implemented and executed throughout.
And for that we need supporters, and we need
supporters often that come from the top of
the company.
This is something that people need to believe
in, top down, in order to be executed throughout
in the right way.
I think number six is with design the solution
to the problem will be different every time.
It isn't you know design isn't formulaic,
five-step or ten-step program.
It has to be, both the process and the outcome
has to be custom made, custom thought.
I find this fascinating today because there's
so many different companies coming into realization
that design is important.
Pharmaceutical companies, distribution, shipping,
logistics companies.
I mean all kinds of unexpected people realize
how much better design can realize things
for them.
The process is fundamentally different.
And we need to accept that I think.
I think the time of sort of consultants presenting
you the five-step program.
And by the time we get to number five you'll
have good design in place.
>>Google Rep: Ten times more revenue.
>>Yves: Hmm?
>>Yves: Yes.
>>Google Rep: ROI is high.
>>Yves: Isn't gonna work.
So design is really about finding solutions
that are gonna be unique and a process that's
gonna deliver those solutions, it's gonna
be probably different every time.
And then finally, this is never ask customers
what they want, ask them about their aspirations.
I think it is our job, the job of the designer
to conceive of the future.
I do think it's important to listen to people,
I think it's important to listen to people
before you start and after and during the
process.
But asking them what their future should be
like is, you know I don't think it's gonna
work as well as designers who are sort of
living and breathing this process all the
time.
And who will also bring.
I mean I've quoted this recently, you know
if you ask people when the Ford Model T was
built, Mr. Ford said, "If you asked people
what they wanted back then, they would have
said faster horses."
And designers thought of the car.
>>Google Rep: So if you guys weren't paying
attention, it was seven.
>>Yves: Seven yes.
>>Google Rep: So less but better right?
Dieter Rams had ten principals, you have seven.
[Laughter]
>>Yves: Yes.
I don't mean to improve on Dieter but.
[Laughter]
>>Google Rep: All right I need the card back,
it's scripted.
>>Yves: Oh yes.
[Laughter]
>>Google Rep: What's the next question?
Lets see.
Alright, give us a sense of how you approach
design.
So is there something uniquely Baharian?
>>Yves: I've never heard that, Baharian.
>>Google Rep: Baharian Yes.
[Laughter]
I coined it, trademarked it.
I have a patent on it.
>>Yves: Usually we do that well.
[Laughter]
So it isn't about style, and certainly we
tend to base our work in ideas.
And we tend to really find some way to speak
of something or a way to express something
or the way to make everyone kind of inspired
or delighted by a certain product or a certain
digital or physical or the offering of a business.
We try to find that key notion that is an
aspiration that may exist but hasn't been
sort of fulfilled yet.
And that becomes our key notion, our key principle.
And I can probably go back, it is a little
bit abstract but I can go back to probably
almost every product we've done and say this
was the key moment, the key idea we tried
to express.
Through all these kind of executions, that
we try to express in the product.
>>Google Rep: So what was the...
>>Yves: Let me see if I have something to
illustrate that.
I don't know but, yes, that's for the next
question.
>>Google Rep: So what was the hardest lesson
you've had to learn in your career?
I mean people obviously probably know about
most of your successes.
But I think it's always interesting to just
learn a little bit about what difficulties
you've faced and kinda what that taught you.
>>Yves: Well the whole point is that you wouldn't
know about the numerous things that didn't
work.
[Laughter]
They tend to remain; sadly, they tend to remain
in someone's drawer.
And that's the biggest frustration as a designer
I think is to see your product, and I'm sure
you experience this here as well.
>>Google Rep: [whispers] Yeah.
>>Yves: Is to see your product kind of locked
up in somebodies drawer.
The other lesson for me is that it's possible
for us to move mountains as designers but
the mountains have to want to move.
Which means simply that when you're brought
in as a designer in a situation where there
isn't really a will to go someplace new or
to experiment or to discover or to get on
a journey, it becomes very difficult to do.
And I probably spent most of the 90's here
in Silicon Valley feeling pretty miserable
about how people were looking at design.
You know back then it was, there was no clear
ROI on design.
Nobody, you know the first question you would
get from anybody in business is, "Really,
I need to work with you guys?
My marketing guy says so or my wife."
And they would be like, "C'mon between us,
what's the ROI on design.
Tell me."
Cause you know.
>>Google Rep: It's like a dirty secret or
something.
>>Yves: Yeah it's like we all know there is
none right?
>>Google Rep: And that you're a con man.
>>Yves: So that was a pretty miserable time.
And I think that the last 10-15 years have
been really really good for us.
>>Google Rep: So help us understand what changed
that.
The 90's and post the 2001 crash.
>>Yves: Well I think we have Steve Jobs to
thank for our credibility, our newly found
credibility in business.
Without Apple and without Steve Jobs, the
ROI would be somewhat unclear.
And with Steve Jobs and Apple, the ROI is
pretty clear.
And of course others have done it.
I mean companies like Target and companies,
numerous start-ups obviously.
And it seems today that we have a complete
reversal of the attitude.
It seems like people know pretty clearly that
design is gonna play a key role in any new
type of venture or in the future of any mature
type of business.
>>Google Rep: But is that achieved in a sustainable
way?
Steve jobs has passed away.
Apple will at one point cease to exist.
What makes design fundamentally important?
Or is this change that you've seen in Silicon
Valley here to stay?
>>Yves: I think the change that happened in
the 50's both in Europe and in the United
States around design having a key role has
still impact today, you know 60, 70 years
later.
The work of the people I showed before is
celebrated all around the world.
Still derives economic value.
And certainly there was a lot of cultural
value both for this country and the rest of
the world.
So I do think that historically the value
of design has been established by companies
like Herman Miller and you know maybe Knoll
as well obviously.
And that's still something that obviously
you guys live with.
>>Google Rep: Yeah.
And so how does working with a Herman Miller
compare to working with maybe a more purely
technology firm?
You know like a furniture, a very physical
object versus the more digital kind of Silicon
Valley based products.
>>Yves: You know I'm one of the people who
say it's not different at all.
For me the process which you can see online,
the process we use to develop the sail chair
here is the same kind of process we're using
to develop a digital product or a very technologically
advanced product.
It's a lot of thinking about the user.
It's a lot about thinking about new technologies
or new ways of doing things or what are new
you know socio-economic kind of factors in
place that will influence the work that is
done now?
And it's a lot about sketching and trying
and falling and trying again and making mock-ups
and building and rebuilding and testing and
breaking.
I mean the process of design as being iterative,
as kind of pushing the boundaries and stretching
the notion of what's possible, all of that
is very much the same.
>>Google Rep: And what about the role of actual
technology in the design process.
What do you guys use, what do you guys rely
on?
And how important is it in you know improving
the design process?
>>Yves: So the role of technology is in many
ways central and in many ways it is not.
Ideas aren't technology generated.
Drawing sketches, quick iterative things tend
to be done by hand.
We draw, I mean for this chair here which
you are seeing in more of an advertising shot
for it, we generated about 70 functioning
prototypes just within our studio.
Probably 100+ with the partnership with Herman
Miller.
We generated thousands of drawings.
Just like for a user flow or a user interface
or, you would generate lots and lots of different
iterations.
All centered for one idea.
Our process is never about splattering the
world of possibilities on the wall and showing
a client oh these are the 20 different ways
this can be done.
What we do instead is we pick one thing that
we think would be really extraordinary, really
amazing to deliver.
Really sort of puts you over the top right.
And we go really really deep into that and
keep trying to reach this magical place.
But technology has a role when it comes to
building other types of prototypes.
Digital prototypes, physical engineering prototypes.
When it comes to testing.
When it comes to sort of getting feedback.
When it comes to doing research.
Technology has an important role there.
But I don't see it, I really see it as a tool,
I don't see it as the reason why you would
do anything.
Google Rep: And so in that process where you're
coming up with thousands of drawings or hundreds
of prototypes right, where do you guys go
or where does Yves go for inspiration?
Like what inspires you, like what are you
doing in your daily life?
What are the most important drivers of like
the thoughts in there?
>>Yves: So I'm not somebody who's gonna go
and look at, just tell you that oh nature
inspires everything that we do.
I'm much more sort of a product of our, the
numerous, the thousands of different inputs,
the cultural inputs.
Everyday life inputs that we get in our lives.
That said my life is almost split.
I have a city life that's very intense, an
office life that's very intense.
I tend to work with clients all over the world,
in urban centers.
And so culture is a very important role in
what we do, travel technology.
You know there is sort of the intensity of
work and urban centers is important.
But then I also have a whole part of my life
which I spend in nature physically.
I surf, I spend time in a little village up
North, you know, the coast.
And this is where the neurons are still firing
and everything processes.
But the environment is sort of cleaned up
for inspiration and ideas to come.
I mean I'm not someone who, to me everything
is mixed.
I mean it not like I go to this little place
and this is where I get all my ideas.
I think for most of us inspiration happens
all the time, continuously.
And our jobs allow us to do that right?
I mean were not sort of expected to be just
doing one thing today, were expected to be,
to have multiple roles, to have multiple ways
to input into the process.
And I think that helps in some ways.
>>Google Rep: So this seems tied to your concept
of holistic making a little bit maybe then.
Can you, I think some people might be familiar
with her, but can you help, perhaps explain
this a little bit more, this kind of concept
I think you're trying to bring to the conscious?
>>Yves: Yeah, you know holistic making for
me is the opportunity designers have today
to take that 360° view and to really again
not be used as just the problem solver for
one problem which is a graphic problem or
a user interface or a user experience problem
or a physical product problem.
What is being seen is somebody who can create
cohesiveness across a lot of these different
places.
And I think it's widely understood today that
consumer experiences cannot have disconnected
points.
They have to be, what we are doing now is
we're really sort of serving entire brand
ecosystems in a way that doesn't have these
points of disconnects.
Because those get noticed immediately.
Those get, those points get pointed out immediately.
And as designers we can now look at things
like, I mean this is a very physical thing
but it's kind of a cute project.
We can look, you know we're giving these sort
of problems which is, oh why don't you rethink
the chandelier?
And then you go well, what people love about
chandeliers for centuries is all this sparkling
little lights and the reflections and the
sort of rainbow colors that happened when
the light hits it.
And then in a holistic way you're like okay
so that's the experience I think people are
looking for.
Not this ancient physical thing that has like
thousands of crystals and you know 20 or 30
lights or candles in the past on it.
And we built this thing out of, not all the
reflections and all the magic and with one
crystal and one specially tuned LED light.
And so holistically we looked at the effect,
we looked at the sustainability in our proposition.
We looked at the attainability, making it
affordable rather than very expensive.
So this has a bond that makes this a product
that can be retailed for $100, right.
So we can look at all these different elements
including the packaging and say this is a
holistic experience.
Or it's looking at physical products like
what I'm wearing here.
Or the first LED light here.
But also the way you touch it and the way
it feels under hand pressure and looking at
that first touch interface, this is a touch
interface before everything became touch,
you know before the iPhone.
Google Rep: what year was this?
Yves: That was 2006.
Yes.
>>Google Rep: So just before the.
>>:Yves: It's hard to imagine.
>>Google Rep: Yeah, I know.
[Laughter]
>>Google Rep: Kids nowadays grow up with TV
screens that are broken right?
>>Yves: So this you know you would just touch
the surface there was no button to turn it
on and off.
You just, you could change the intensity of
the light or the coloration of the life.
And to me that's sort of, you know all of
this is sort of holistic making.
Including thinking about the social ramifications
of what is that we do.
In many ways, businesses can't really afford
to not look at sustainability or the social
impact that they have as part of the product,
as part of what it is that they make.
>>Google Rep: One laptop per trial basis.
>>Yves: This is in Peru and they have 1 million
laptops in Peru.
So we do a lot of nonprofit work.
We do a lot of, just like Google of course.
We do a lot of projects that try to bring
the intelligence of designs back to the widest
possible audience.
>>Google Rep: And how do you justify the ROI
of those products?
>>Yves: That's a good question.
We don't really; I think there's an ROI in
how you feel when you get up in the morning.
>>Google Rep: So the emotions, yeah.
[Laughter]
>>Yves: I think there is.
That said, I mean I don't want to, these are
other things that we do.
Or you know, like looking at sustainability
as this incredible opportunity to make the
entire experience better, not to make something
recyclable or reusable or using less energy.
But actually looking at the engagement at
the end and making that even better.
So we can think about all these things holistically.
But this is a program that I'm particularly
excited about and proud of because in many
ways this is a nonprofit program for the government
of Mexico at a nonprofit in Mexico that distributes
eyeglasses to children.
They can pick the top and bottom colors so
they become really involved into their own
glasses.
There's a big stigma everywhere in the world,
but in South America against wearing glasses.
And so this makes them more personal and makes
them wear them.
But as designers we can figure out how these
things are built, how they're robust, how
they cost five dollars to make including the
custom-made lenses.
But then so you do something like this which
is nonprofit and then working under these
extreme constraints makes you look at the
entire value chain and the entire logistics
system in a new way.
>>Google Rep: Down to the actual object?
>>Yves: Down to the actual object, but also
the distribution, how they're picked.
And then what you realize is I did something
for this nonprofit but there is a whole business
model here.
So we're building a for-profit version of
this sort of starting from the nonprofit and
going to the for-profit version of this which
will finance the nonprofit, but also create
sustainable business.
We just now launched actually a bus that's
in the East Bay that's distributing eyeglasses,
these very eyeglasses.
>>Google Rep: The same ones that are going
to Mexico?
>>Yves: Yeah the same ones to kids up here.
So we're already moving some of the aspects
of the nonprofit out here.
>>Google Rep: And the "One Laptop per Child"
is a similar story right?
It was meant for Africa but it's been used
all over, right?
>>Yves: Yeah I mean in a way the $100 laptop
kind of made this idea that a smaller lighter
computer is something that was desirable which
we had heard from certain people in industry
that it wasn't.
>>Google Rep: MacBook Air.
>>Yves: And so in a way it kind of, and Google
is a huge supporter of the $100 laptop.
So in a way it kind of initiated maybe a different
look at the space.
But it's most prominent now, the $100 laptop
is most prominent in South America..
>>Google Rep: Wow.
Which is totally different from its original,
I mean the original mission was Africa.
>>Yves: Well it was global.
But the first large task and the first large
distributions were in...
>>Google Rep: Sub-Saharan Africa
>>Yves: Yeah.
>>Google Rep: So, what is Yves dream project?
I mean you've had the chance to work on chairs;
you've had the chance to work on glasses.
You've had the chance to work on quantified
self wristbands.
What is your dream project in many ways?
>>Yves: So my advice to all designers is not
to have a dream project.
Because if you have a dream project and you're
not gonna consider everything that you worked
on as a potential dream project.
And I can promise you, I can assure you that
in the first couple of meetings that I had
with Puma and they're like, "We want you to
rethink our shoebox", and it's like oh, can
I work on
the shoes?
[Laughter]
Until I realized wow no, the shoebox is gonna
have a much bigger impact.
The shoebox is 80 million shoes that get shipped
around by this one brand and the consequences
rather than a small kind of hipster line of
shoes that gets into a few kind of cool stores.
I realize the impact of the shoebox is actually
so much bigger, so much more important, so
much more long-lasting.
And so I turned the shoebox into, what many
people would now consider a dream project.
Because you have this big impact, because
it's global.
>>Google Rep: That chart you were showing
before.
>>Yves: Yeah.
This one.
And so many of the projects that have come
through to us, I'm just somebody who gets
really excited about the really big potential
of it.
I tend to see beyond maybe even the frame
and the limits that clients have brought us
these projects within those frames and limits.
And I think I've turned a few and the team
at Fuseproject has turned a few things into
potential dream project.
But I can guarantee you that's not what they
seem to be at the onset.
And so I think that's the best..
>>Google Rep: Dream project.
>>Yves: Yeah, that's the best one to live
in a way.
>>Google Rep: Yeah, without a dream project.
>>Yves: Cause if you're constantly thinking
about if I worked on a car, or if I worked
on a train, then I would really make it.
Then I would live the designer dream.
You can spend a career waiting for that.
>>Google Rep: So let's get a little more abstract
then.
What is the biggest challenge that you think
design needs to solve in the coming years,
decades right?
What are you most excited about in terms of
maybe a space.
>>Yves: Well I think the things that design
is gonna solve are a few simple notions.
I mean every business is gonna become sustainable
one way or the other.
There's absolutely no way the current infrastructure
is gonna remain as is.
So at every stage when you're rethinking the
way things are done, the way things are built,
the way things are shipped, the way things
are consumed, sustainability is gonna have
a very important role in that.
And that means that designers have this amazing
opportunity to participate in things like
the puma shoebox which is a logistics and
distribution...
>>Google Rep: Manufacturer.
>>Yves: Manufacturing type of problem.
But also a consumer, an engagement type of
design opportunity.
And so I think everything is gonna have to
be rethought in this way. and when you have
to remake every factory or when you have to
reconceive the way everything is made designers
I gonna have an incredible role to play in
that.
I also think that technology is the other
huge opportunity because technology has still
numerous barriers.
And in many ways making it attainable in the
sense of easy, approachable sort of magical,
not disruptive.
I mean just looking at the idiosyncrasies
of the ways that we use technology today.
There's some huge improvements that are gonna
go on.
And they're gonna in my opinion be design
driven.
>> Google Rep: Great, so I've asked all the
questions that I have.
I think there's a number of Googlers here
that would love to have a time or a chance
that's the question.
So I opened it up to the audience.
Looks like there's one back there.
>> Male #1: [Inaudible]
>>Yves: Yeah, so the question is what is the
proportion of time that I spend or maybe my
team spends coming up with ideas versus implementing
them?
You know sort of crafting the sort of final
bits of those products or those experiences.
You know it's to me, if we don't spend the
time to be there all the way through, til
the final implementation, til the final refinement.
If we're not there at the end sort of doing
quality control to make sure that the big
idea, the big design, the visual, the experience
we've created isn't exactly as conceived at
the end, were gonna ship products that are
gonna be mediocre.
Or that are not gonna achieve their full potential.
So we actually spent a lot of time at the
very onset.
You know what's the name of the company, what's
the big story here?
Making the product again digital and physical.
And testing it and using it and living with
it.
All the way through the end so that when it
comes out the design criteria, the things
you get excited about in the beginning.
The pillars that you created for this brand
of product are still there.
So for me it's completely critical that as
designers we stay engaged all the way through.
And it's not just like passing the baton to
a developer or to an engineering group for
to a manufacturer.
You really have to be there all the way.
That just means just engaging over a long
period of time and being fully supported in
that engagement obviously with whoever you
work with.
>>Male #2: So on that topic, my question is
actually about platforms and what role design
takes in actually establishing or building
or creating platforms that other people build
upon.
And what role, I mean can you have like the
iPhone, [inaudible] Android or better microphones.
When other people ultimately have to build
on thing that you've created.
Is there sort of a hand off, how far do go
down the path of making things fairly restrictive
in terms of the things that people built or
even like the old PC, like the apps that people
would build there.
How do you communicate I guess the things
you were trying to achieve and help them actually
extend the value of what you are creating
as opposed to diminish that value?
>>Yves: I think it's essential to create products
and experiences that fit within the current
ethos which is people want to be able to modify,
change, own this sort of just in time mentality
that we are all experiencing today.
I'm taking a picture and I'm posting it immediately,
I wasn't doing that, I wouldn't take the picture
anymore.
I mean it used to be that I would wait a week
for that picture to be developed and handed
back to me.
So in many ways I think the platforms have
to sort of tap into what simply is the current
way everybody lives which is instance.
You know and at the same time you want to
be able to have some things there that ensure
level of quality or level of even potentially
design.
But I think it's an interesting mix between
providing a well-designed platform that is
sort of solid and exciting and that people
really want and at the same time leaving enough
there for other people to own and to build
on top of.
So I think that's definitely very different
from designing products that never change.
That, or that are very restrictive in a sense.
>>Google Rep: Pass it to, down there.
>>Male #3: Hi.
So you said your number one design principle
is to think about the user experience and
not really asked aesthetics.
In your mind, what's an example of a really
ugly but well-designed product?
[Laughter]
>>Yves: I don't know, I mean I don't know
if the paperclip is ugly, I don't think it's
ugly.
I don't know that that product would be ugly
on purpose unless sort of there was a reason
for it to be ugly.
Do you have something in mind?
>>Male #3: No, no.
I was just wondering, I'm trying to understand
the principle.
>>Yves: I mean in many ways I think for something
to be beautiful is a function as well.
It isn't just, you know I don't see the two
elements as separate.
So I think you probably have some very useful
things that are very ugly.
I mean I'm sure I see them every day.
But that doesn't mean that, that doesn't make
them sort of the perfect product or the end
all and be all of what this thing could be
or do for you.
>>Male #4: So you talked about the role that
industrial design comes in 90s style more
and more.
Also taking on strategy, understanding how
to transform organizations to be successful.
Given that though, what is the differentiating
role of the traditional industrial design
aspect of form giving, of speaking through
form.
Is that still relevant as a differentiator?
I mean we are now competing against strategy
firms, against firms that don't have the design
aspect but maybe covering a lot of other aspects
that organizations are looking for.
>>Yves: I think that there were certainly
in the 90s a whole tendency to go towards
management consulting.
And I think there are all kinds of interesting
reasons to do that, but they're not the ones
that are we're shaping our firm around.
We believe in making.
I believe in organizational change by making,
by example.
I do believe that when projects, anywhere
in any business kind of sort of acquire a
level of success by having been done differently
or by proving that the company can do things
differently or achieve things differently
is a much better way to do management change
or education than just trying to have a few
brainstorms with top management.
And so I think what you need to find though
is you need to find companies that will open
up the door for this to happen.
That will say okay well we'll give a chance
with something different to happen and prove
that there is a new approach that we are not
familiar with that could be successful.
And we find more and more of those companies
now.
We're not really competing because we don't
deliver a strategy product, or we don't deliver,
we don't even deliver a product product per
se only.
You know what we do is we build brands and
we build businesses.
And in that sense...
>>Male #4: But you're taking a recognizable
Fuseproject identity that kind of weaves through
a lot of the physicalness of the product,
like anywhere from perfume bottles, to some
of the watches, to some of the things where
there's some unique aspect I would say is
still there that maybe.
Like consciously people feel attracted to.
>>Yves: Yeah I mean we definitely want people
to be attracted to what we do.
And so being attractive, or being successful
for our products is a key element, and I could
certainly say that that's intentional, that's
something we look for.
We don't really, unless there is a role of
more of a laboratory type of project or an
experimental type project the goal is certainly
for things to reach as many people as possible
and make whatever idea or business or experience
understood and adopted and loved.
>>Google Rep: Alright, well I think we're
out of time.
If you still have a question you should come
up and ask Yves but let's all thank him for
coming in.
[Applause]
>>Yves: Thank you.
>>Google Rep: Thank you.
>>Yves: Thanks very much.
>>Google Rep: That was awesome.